the star I am about to introduce is one
of our loveliest like a painter she has
achieved the canvas of performances as
varied and as beautiful as herself last
year she took home a golden Oscar for
the best performance by an actress
tonight she will present the award for
the best performance by an actor which
makes the winner a doubly lucky fellow
ladies and gentlemen miss Loretta Young
I know how unforgettable this evening is
going to be for the winner and I know
how much the sense of trust and faith
that comes with Oscar will mean to him
I am very proud and happy to present the
Award for the Best Performance by an
actor the nominees are Lew Ayres and
Johnny Belinda Warner Brothers
Montgomery Clift in the search craisins
films Metro Golda Meir Swiss Dan Dailey
in when my baby smiles at me 20th
Century Fox Laurence Olivier and Hamlet
junior rank Two Cities film universal
international British Clifton Webb in
sitting pretty 20th Century Fox and the
winner Laurence Olivier
you